Et que son institutrice lui avait interdit
l'accès aux toilettes des garçons.
Et elle avait bu 2 verres de ce jus de fruit rouge
à la fête d'Halloween,
et bon, qui peut résister à ce jus de fruit, hein ? Il est si bon.
Et elle n'a pu se retenir plus longtemps.
Elle et ses camarades de classe avaient 4 ans.
Elles se sentaient déjà suffisamment fortes
pour l'empêcher d'accéder aux toilettes soi-disant publiques.
Elle avait quatre ans.
Elle avait déjà appris une dure leçon :
à la maternelle, il n'y a pas de porte de toilettes
avec dessus un symbole pour les gens comme elle.
Elle avait déjà appris que les toilettes allaient être un problème
et que le problème venait d'elle,
et uniquement d'elle.
Donc, mon amie m'a demandé de parler à sa petite fille,
ce que j'ai fait.
Je voulais lui dire
qu'avec sa mère, nous allions aller
parler aux responsables de l'école et que le problème serait résolu
mais je savais que c'était faux.
Je voulais lui dire que tout s'arrangerait quand elle grandirait,
mais je ne pouvais pas.
Je lui ai donc demandé de me raconter ce qui s'était passé
et de me dire ce qu'elle avait ressenti.
« Furieuse et triste »,
elle m'a dit.
Alors je lui ai dit
qu'elle n'était pas seule
et que ce qu'elle avait vécu était injuste,
et elle m'a demandé si j'avais déjà fait pipi dans ma culotte.
Je lui ai dit que oui,
mais pas depuis très longtemps.
(Rires)
Ce qui était bien sûr un mensonge,
parce que, vous savez, quand vous avez 42 ou 43 ans,
il peut vous arriver d'avoir des petites fuites urinaires
quand vous toussez ou éternuez,
quand vous montez les escaliers en courant ou que vous vous étirez.
Ne mentez pas.
Cela arrive, non ?
Je pense qu'elle n'a pas besoin de savoir ça.
(Rires)
Je lui ai dit qu'en grandissant, sa vessie grandirait aussi.
Quand elle serait aussi vieille que moi,
elle pourrait se retenir très longtemps de faire pipi.
Je lui ai promis.
« Jusqu'à ce que tu rentres chez toi ? »,
elle m'a demandé.
J'ai dit : « Oui,
jusqu'à ce que tu rentres. »
Je crois que cela l'a réconfortée un peu.
Alors construisons juste des toilettes individuelles « neutres »
avec un petit banc pour pouvoir se mettre en tenue de sport.
Nous ne pouvons changer le monde du jour au lendemain
pour nos enfants,
mais nous pouvons leur offrir un lieu sûr et privé
où se réfugier hors du monde,
même si ce n'est que pour une minute.
Ça, nous pouvons le faire.
Alors faisons-le.
Si certains d'entre vous, parmi l'assemblée,
ont déjà plein de raisons en tête pour dire que ce n'est pas la priorité,
que cela coûte trop cher,
ou que proposer aux transgenres un lieu sûr où faire pipi
ou se changer,
favorise un style de vie qui offense leur morale
leur masculinité,
ou leurs croyances religieuses,
alors laissez-moi parler
à cette partie de votre cœur, qui j'ose l'espérer,
se soucie du reste de l'humanité.
Si vous ne vous inquiétez pas assez pour des gens comme moi,
qu'en sera-t-il des femmes et filles
qui ont des problèmes d'image corporelle ?
De tous ceux qui ont des problèmes d'image corporelle ?
Qu'en sera-t-il de ce garçon à l'école qui mesure 30 cm de moins que ses camarades,
et dont la voix n'a pas encore mué ? Hein ?
Oh, l'année de la quatrième,
comme tu peux être cruelle,
non ?
Qu'en sera-t-il des gens avec des maladies nerveuses ?
Avec des handicaps ou qui ont besoin d'assistance ?
Qu'en sera-t-il de gens au corps qui, pour une raison ou une autre,
ne colle pas à l'image du corps tel qu'on pense qu'il doit être ?
Combien d'entre nous sont encore intimidés
ou ont peur de se dévoiler face à leurs pairs
et combien d'entre nous laisse cette peur
les empêcher de faire quelque chose d'aussi important
que le sport ?
Toutes ces personnes ne profiteraient-elles pas
de ces toilettes individuelles ?
Nous ne pouvons pas changer les esprits anti-transgenres du jour au lendemain
mais on peut donner à chacun
un lieu pour se changer
et travailler tous ensemble
et créer un monde plus sûr
pour tous.
Merci de m'avoir écouté.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.